cette année pour remplir sa hotte le
père noël va devoir parcourir plusieurs
kilomètres
premier arrêt saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
c'est ici qu est implanté son taux ce
faire cette société existe depuis plus
de 30 ans elle imagine dans ses locaux
des jeux sensoriels inspiré de la
méthode montessori ou encore des kits de
loisirs créatifs c'est pas uniquement le
petit jeu sur lequel on joue pendant dix
minutes c'est réellement des choses on
va avoir un apprentissage on va avoir et
on est vraiment sur le premier le
principe de faire les choses soi-même de
réaliser des choses on est dans un monde
où on va de plus en plus vite c'est
aussi des jeux qui vont prendre leur
temps avec ses boîtes en carton 100%
recyclable sentosphère mise aussi sur
l'écologie une valeur partagée par une
autre société
direction versailles où s'est installée
depuis peu le siège social de nature et
découvertes
depuis sa création en 1990 l'enseigne
s'est spécialisé dans les produits de
bien-être des produits également liés à
la biodiversité
parmi les cadeaux plébiscités cette
année ce nichoirs pour oiseaux ou encore
ces jouets pour les tout petits
et nous avons aussi cette année leur
lancement de notre gamme pour les 0 à 3
ans qui s'appelle gallopin des bois qui
est une gamme devait jouer très
vertueuse parce que nous n'utilisons que
du coton bio pour les enfants nous
utilisons du bois fsc de forêts gérées
durablement et enfin dieu la peinture
sans solvant pour les plus grands nature
et découvertes mise notamment sur une
valeur sûre la lecture un mes coups de
coeur en livrent en ce moment c'est le
livre vivre avec la terre de charles
hervé gouyer de la ferme du bec hellouin
qui nous apprend les grands principes de
la permaculture et qui est un très très
beau cadeau à offrir
[Musique]
depuis 2015 la nostalgie à son royaume à
houilles
c'est ici qu est installée la société
naftal gift points comme ce site
internet propose des articles sur le
thème de la nostalgie des jouets des
bonbons qui nous font voyager dans le
temps
3000 produits sont référencés on voit
souvent dans les tendances les gens qui
créent leur coffret avec plein de petits
bonbons et justement ils vont mettre un
jeu d'eau agnès et vous faire leur petit
coffret pour que les imagine les
personnes retombe en enfance
des coffrets nostalgique proposé entre
30 et 40 euros